dieser zug bringt sie zu den gedanken
dass sie würden keinen völlig heißen
jetzt wollen dass cherry soll
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein name ist jonas ems als auch
bischofs institut für berufsbildung und
gesäß ihrem sechsten lebensjahr gar
nicht mehr aufs tempo 60 fahren werden
[Musik]
gewitter effekt riskieren kanton
fribourg radiomachen spruch unter zwei
prozent sieht wiedergeburt schon
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn er im fernsehen dieser anblick
vorgeschlagen womit vor allem dank so
eine sache endlich technik prozess ist
die persönliche weniger ludwigshafen und
da seien unbedingt wollte
[Musik]
kochen
die wartungspreise häufig damit
konfrontiert wie sie überhaupt aus plan7
unter der karosserie eigentlich gar
nicht erhältlich
[Musik]
die stadtwerke über noch große blüten
lehrer kennen
und das nachdem ihr unbedingt wichtig
und hat sega das ist spaß macht ausüben
in der türkei sein
[Musik]
danke andere sind und dank der bgh
niemals mehrfach neben reise aufs handy
dann haben
tokio
im hotel ist hier
kambodscha
hier
[Musik]
links nach links und dann die straße auf
das ist etwas was von oben links sondern
wenn wir einfach mal los
aber so zählen
fertig
hollerith jochen rothenbacher schlagen
sondern wir für unsere user finden wie
das jetzt in einer stadt wo die
verschiedenen religionen erhält vor
allem konflikte kataloge wie gut dass
die teilnahme der status ja aber
parieren
braucht die hilfe mitgliedsstaat ist
dass ihr opa altstadt
nein wartet die straßen wartet jetzt
könnt ihr gehen
dazu ein bisschen nervös kein wunder ich
sehr gespannt wie es um gange und rosa
bis vor deiner verschiedenen religionen
merkt im umgang mit abstand eine
bedeutende winterkamp abgeordnete graben
[Musik]
erzeugen
mit dem rauen hauptstadt
sorry touristischer faktor genannt
willkommen in palästina das hier war
einmal palästina
jetzt ist das israelisch
palästinensischer fiedler links ist das
christliche viertel und das armenische
[Musik]
eine israelische sim-karte wollte für
wie viele tage
[Musik]
er muss euch einen fairen preis machen
er haut euch nur ein bisschen über
suchen so mein freund kann ich dein
handy haben
ja ja
öffne das blut schafft vertrauen aber es
ist ja mal gemerkt man muss spüren
ja wenn du gut oder unterhält
und was ist das passwort
seid ihr zufrieden mit ihm wie werden
wir das nicht
[Musik]
ja
was jetzt
[Musik]
ja
nein nein ihr müsst hier runter und dann
links
wenn ihr möchtet kann ich euch
hinbringen
[Musik]
ja ja ja
von raphael
da es gerade links rechts
optisch erinnert bis das haus hat es
druck durch
das gras
aber es hängen hier wollt ihr zur klage
in meiner hand in meine hand die
jobsuche nein ich bin tour guide
man braucht einfach nicht ihm aber auf
dem kopf
den hut könnt ihr auf die kipper tun
verstand nicht genau wir uns in der kita
aber das hat sechsjährigen eigenbetrieb
[Musik]
ja schon gut hier muss einer krippe im
chor wie der unimog wie der gedächtnis
großes juli oder das nicht mehr so nach
lina teil vom hof bedeckt
das ist die klage nun fragt sonst
einfach um hilfe das ist kein problem
ok schönen tag
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist doch so religiöser ort der messe
mit
wir haben nicht noch mal die
liedermacher stellt
haben wir das
ja
jerusalem ich lebe in israel aber
ursprünglich komme ich aus paris spricht
die französische jeden montag und
donnerstag nehmen wir die tore heraus
wie alle juden und so hat es heute auch
viele war mit 2
[Applaus]
[Musik]
damit weist wie die erstkommunion bei
den katholiken
mit 13 jahren wird hier der junge zum
man vorher trägt der vater die
verantwortung für die taten seines
sohnes ab 13 jahren trägt der sohn
selbst die verantwortung
alles alles gute
[Musik]
nicht anders die monat oder ja
ja
wie gut das ganze hat die natur die
ritter im vorfeld gefragt wird die dcc
haben wir sind ganz andere vorstellungen
das papier mäckler und und der
besteuerungsanteil tankten mit dem
vorort szene über minister wünscht ruf
ein start nach mass
es ist dafür wünscht sich das nicht
somit wird er gar
[Musik]
das geht es kunst
das granulat europa bedarf dafür stellt
das so
der post trotz netter mensch
qiagen qiagen in thüringen haben
jüdische friedhof
sie wünschte sich die anhebung
ich glaube schon sehr stark 3 das ist
also das ist da passiert ist
ich glaube daran dass ist dass es die
macht geht und darum hoffen natürlich
dass die wünsche in erfüllung gehen
[Musik]
männer
aus vorgestellt jetzt kommt ich helfe
euch die nächste doch noch klar ihr
könnt sie mir geben
[Musik]
destinationen
seit 1
die jacke
für jan die cia sprach es gab durchaus
vor lässt was auf dem bildschirm steht
und das macht es möglich dass mir die
englische schluss sicher andere bedienen
damit sprach es gab gegen schnell wurde
gestellt und die arme verstöße also
schon extrem lang so sprachausgabe
brauchen
nach 100 metern
mit krone und alle taxi
als hallo süße wie sie darum blind
nichts konnte nach vorne
[Musik]
da geht mir das selbst alles
hallo
ich trage immer auszumachen opfer
zitiere stoxx hinein aber zehn meter
weiter vorne wartet ein ja kein problem
ich habe gewartet
[Musik]
ja
das sind ja
dass die umsicht spüre probieren und
doch besitzt auch nicht dass das klima
zu spüren
warum darf der luft braucht die hilfe
und sagte was man da sehr viel
es ist sozusagen die gesamte sicht auch
die altstadt von jerusalem
im zentrum ist der felsendom ist blau
und seine kumpel ist aus gold
[Musik]
wir sind auf der seite des jüdischen
friedhofes
auf der anderen seite des tals unterhalb
der stadtmauer befindet sich der
muslimischen friedhof also weiterhin
gute reise beschrieben
es war hart
naja man oft das thema
[Musik]
gutgeschrieben
das gleiche sie ja da ist doch wo sie
ohnehin und ja
[Musik]
felipe massa braus und die für eine
partei mehr allem in nordamerika verlief
wurden stetig sie das dass das einmalige
erlebnis das gefühl vorsorglich auf dem
wasser können ja dass das dass wir mit
geräten
[Musik]
mehr als toter mehr als taktik noch hier
crm ist nicht so einfach mit der
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel und man
jetzt auch leben informiert und
herausgefunden dass ist am einfachsten
wenn man das toxin a vis eigentlich 40
minuten aber manchmal hatte städtischen
im iran ja oder nein
man kann die häuser sehen auf der
jordanischen seite des toten meeres
wir fahren nun richtung jericho
das ist eine straße für alle die
palästinenser können sie benutzen aber
auch diese rallye weil sie in die
westbank geht aber auch zu jüdischen
siedlungen führt rechts könnt ihr die
mauer sehen zwischen israel und
palästina brand
der checkpoint
nein weil wir in diese richtung fahren
auf der anderen seite schaut mal da hat
es sehr viele autos
sie haben einen palästinensischen pass
ich gehöre zu den arabern die in
jerusalem leben
wir haben entweder einen iranischen pass
und eine israel id oder einige haben die
israelische staatsbürgerschaft jerusalem
klapper
es ist sehr schön und speziell ein segen
ich bin hier geboren und unser haus
gehört meiner familie seit der
jordanischen zeit
wir werden unsere häuser nicht verlassen
verlass ist
aber sie ist mag ich nicht auch
schwierig sehr schwierig sehr
aber was können wir machen wir müssen
geduldig sein
ich habe viele israelische freunde weil
ich in einem hotel gearbeitet habe es
gibt auf beiden seiten gute menschen und
schlechte auf beiden seiten
nein nur die politik ist das problem der
politik sind die menschen egal
sie kümmert sich um anderes es geht ums
geschäft
[Musik]
erst sehr interessant was die machen das
akzeptiert das land oder sektoren wie
ein gutachten das die haben ihren job
merkel hat sich ganz lang gebaut werde
ich mit gewalt zu stoppen
[Musik]
es ist 10 grad heißer als in jerusalem
warum der dass wir sagen wir die höhe
ja wir sind hier 400 meter unter dem
meeresspiegel ihr vorne reiten kinder
auf einem kamel
es geht hier kramer
[Applaus]
danach stehen räume denn einfach ging
vitrine guides mehr oder dort immer noch
ein paar schritte machen
ihr könnt schon etwas reinlaufen
[Musik]
er ist ein freund von mir er wird euch
helfen die schuhe könnt ihr hier lassen
[Musik]
wie ist es grossartig ihr werdet jünger
aussehen machen
[Gelächter]
genießt das ich bin hier wenn er raus
muss
[Musik]
unglaublich ja so super gefühl der der
pflege des knies
die schwarze masse mir die nächste sich
so unglaublich
[Musik]
liegt die auto
es biete
das geld darf
platz
o
hier ist der humus das butterbrot
und hier verlaufen
das anschauen
st
denn hier gibt es damit
ja
kann man ganz anders
da muss ich ja ja ja wo laufen sie hier
vor
[Musik]
zu sehen sind
seine
hoppla
jetzt sehen wir hier da ist dann darf
jetzt nach haus
wie sieht er aus rein zum shoot club
gegangen würde mit dem vorfall sperrte
das selbstverständlich eine regionen
zusammen schulter und quasi auch noch
zurück mit im internet recherchiert und
lag schnell dann ihre website gefunden
und so ziemlich zum rosenkrieg
ich habe euch ein kleines geschenk
mitgebracht eine mütze von unserem club
schutz vor israelischen also ich erzähle
euch mal etwas über den katemann club ok
jerusalem tut nur so als ob es eine
stadt wäre aber das täuscht
es sind drei städte eine für menschen
wie mich nicht orthodoxe eine weitere
statistik der muslimischen und der
christlichen araber und die dritte
statistiker orthodoxen juden
jeder teil hat eigene schulen
einige haben sogar ihren eigenen alle
haben eigene nachbarn eine eigene kultur
und eine eigene sprache
es sind also drei städte aus dass das
jeder böse jäh getrübt
nein da kommen wir versuchen an ort zu
sein an dem sich die drei kulturen der
stadt treffen können
es ist sehr kompliziert aber wir haben
fußballfelder in der ganzen stadt und
schulen mit denen wir arbeiten
von den israelischen siedlungen bis zu
den arabischen stadtteilen ganz im osten
cooler typ sehr unkompliziert oft
schnell zum punkt zum zum club meinte
gemerkt dass ich wirklich sind die
lieder schafft sie die passion erlaubt
für das und merkt dass er nicht
zurückschreckt oder kabarett rick
sanchez - das hat das gespür dafür haben
was habt ihr denn schon alles gesehen
sehen ist vielleicht nicht das richtige
wort
wagemut semino rossi spürte wie heißt
der kunstrasen ist schwierig darauf zu
spielen trainer vom jugend sektor erhält
sie auch palästinenser muslime und
richtet palästinenser nun ja aber es hat
araber ethiopia jede kultur ist
vertreten palästinenser könnten bei uns
beitreten aber wenn die palästinenser
einem jüdischen klub wie unserem
beitreten
bekommen sie probleme mit ihren leuten
in ihren stadtteilen
deshalb nehmen sie nur an den
inoffiziellen aktivitäten von uns teilen
man darf auch nicht in der israelischen
liga spielen wenn man keine israel id
hat wollte er mit einem arabischen vater
sprechen
ich brauche ich englisch arabisch
hebräisch und französisch und ich bin
ich habe mal gespielt aber jetzt bin ich
46 und ich bin anwalt der alltag ist
schwierig hier mithalten
wir können nicht ignorieren dass die
situation hier nicht einfach ist
es gibt viele konflikte aber wenn die
menschen in sich drinnen inspiriert
finden um zusammen zu leben dann können
sie zusammen bleiben wenn wir die
politik beiseite lassen dann können die
menschen ist gut haben miteinander und
das schönste beispiel dafür ist dieser
fußballclub
[Musik]
wenig glück erlebt hast sie alle ihren
tolerant ist schön und passt doch nicht
zusammen
zudem betrifft vor allem oder 5
prima
[Musik]
spannend sind sehr sehr religiös ist
dass diese sofort unterbricht und ist
ein mini und deswegen jährlich noch
schön ist ein großer vorteil dass man
nicht urteilen
der vorteil wieder betreten
[Musik]
die maßnahmen nicht die stadt ganz
anders war schon wir aber der leader
aktie was die 7x was roma läuft so quasi
sondern mir ein deckel wird man die
stadt mit der munition und sprachen mit
der nachricht sprach wohl eher die leute
kennen
[Musik]
das jüdische viertel und hier das
armenische jetzt versteht wie die
altstadt funktioniert sie hier
[Musik]
das defizit hier zu sein ist wirklich
ein grund josi zieht sie sehr schonend
xii ob es wirklich ein traum steht das
sieht gut aus man muss immer koffer und
man dies vor anziehen und kompliziert
kämpfe einfach die
selbstverständlichkeit
deshalb ist zeigt dass man mit diesem
add und das stück also so schiedlich
großartig das können die nicht zu
verzögern
[Musik]